welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
turning to couple with Gayle King and
Anthony Mason and we're gonna begin with
this a new investigation raising serious
questions about some safety claims made
by the maker of a popular car booster
seat for children disturbing video
obtained by Pro Publica shows a child
sized dummy being violently tossed
around during a crash test that booster
seat is currently on the market and
we're getting an exclusive first look at
pro públicas investigation it found that
one manufacturer marketed its booster
seats for children who experts worry may
be too small to be adequately protected
in crashes Kris Van Cleave has been
following all of this Kris good morning
so what do parents need to know
well good morning now there's almost
universal agreement that small kids are
safest in a car seat in the back we want
to be very clear about that but safety
advocates would tell you keep your kid
in the harnessed car seat like this one
until they grow out of it this one is
for kids up to 65 pounds then move them
into a booster seat like this one even
though this says it's good for 40 pounds
and up the boosters lift the kids up so
the seat belt fits a bit like it would
for an adult this booster seat by the
way says it's good for kids 30 pounds
and up and notice that side impact
tested sign we're going to show you that
crash test is something that the seat
maker just doesn't want you to see
Julian Brown was a five-year-old in
constant motion she was about to start
kindergarten in 2016 when her world
changed her parents Jay and Lindsey and
the first thing I did was look back to
check on the girls
Lindsey was driving her two daughters
Jillian and Samantha to daycare when
they were hit on the driver's side near
their Long Island home Jillian was
hunched over I couldn't see her face I
know that they took her out first they
had her laid out on the trunk and they
were doing CPR Julian was the furthest
from the impact strapped into her
Evenflo big kid booster seat while
samantha in a different car seat and
lindsay recovered from their injuries
Jillian never will she was internally
decapitated left paralyzed from the neck
down a ventilator now keeps her alive
how has life changed from that day to
today it's completely
everydays sound hey would you quit man
you don't have Karen for her the Browns
are now suing evenflo but the company
says her booster performed as designed
and Jillian's injuries were primarily
due to the severity of the crash and or
driver error her car seat meets or
exceeds federal standards and was
side-impact crash tested but there's no
federal standard for that tests and
videos of even Flo's crash tests
obtained by ProPublica show booster
seats passing even though the
child-sized test dummy is tossed about
like a rag doll I think the word that I
used to describe them initially was
horrific human beings just aren't built
to survive that amount of movement we
showed the videos to dr. Ben Hoffman a
lead author of car seat recommendations
for the American Academy of Pediatrics
would you want your child in a seat that
performed like that no and there's no
way I would want a child who I know or
knew or loved to be put into a scenario
like that a car seat with a harness
fares better in the crash test the test
dummy largely stays in place in the
booster seat the dummy slips out of the
seat belt shoulder restraint during
depositions obtained by ProPublica
evenflo employees explained the only way
to fail the company's crash test is if
the dummy falls completely out of the
seat or if the seat itself breaks one
saying we side impact test our seats but
I don't think we say that we offer any
type of side impact protection engineer
Eric Dahle acknowledges the movement
seen in the crash test could lead to
serious injuries you could have a
contact with something in the vehicle
so injuries like paralyzing injuries
death serious injury serious injury for
years the Academy of Pediatrics has
recommended kids stay in a car seat with
harness restraints for as long as
possible and should not switch to a
booster seat until at least 40 pounds
matching Canadian regulations until 2007
Evenflo marketed the big kid booster as
safe for kids as young as one as long as
they weighed 30 pounds or more for years
before Jillian's 2016 accident Dali
recommended Evenflo stopped selling
booster seats for children under forty
pounds because they'd be safer in seats
with harnesses dolly who still works for
Evenflo later testified he supported the
decision to stick with the 30 pound
minimum Jillian weighed just under 37
pounds Pro Publica Daniela for at
evenflo touted its side impact test as
something that was rigorous and used
beside impact testing marketing to sell
its big kid booster the test was
anything but rigorous just months before
Jillian's accident even float did change
the height and weight requirements and
the owner's manual but did not notify
customers like the Browns already using
the seats because the company says there
was no safety impact with that change
and years later the company's old
standard is still out there in January
Pro Publica bought a big-kid booster
from even Flo's own website with 30
pounds still on the label just this week
we found signage at an Oregon Walmart
saying the seats were for kids 30 pounds
and up I would never have bought that if
I known I would have left them in the
fund facing five-point harness for years
you know you read it and you believe it
even flow declined our request for an
on-camera interview but said in a
statement the company is a pioneer in
side-impact testing and it provides safe
effective and affordable products adding
it complies with all federal regulations
which do allow booster seats to be sold
for kids weighing 30 pounds and up
Congress has been asking federal
regulators to create a side-impact crash
test standard for car seats since at
least 2000 that standard is yet to go
into effect you can read pro-public his
entire in-depth investigation online now
at CBS news.com
very
opening report I mean even Flo can say
they're a pioneer inside impact testing
but if there's no standard for what the
test is what does it really mean and
other car seat makers are doing testing
too we just don't know what those
results are and really at the bottom
line safety experts say is keep the kid
in the Boosters in that in that harness
as long as possible and focus not on I
think about age when I think about car
seats but in fact sounds like ways what
you got to pay attention to weight and
age absolutely
I keep thinking about the video you
showed if the little girl doing the
cartwheels yes and now that she's on a
ventilator that's tough
she turns nine this month she's in third
grade goes to school every day huh
remarkable girl thank you thank you